[Music]
so this is the bulls hideout
it's a microbrewery but really it's a
front
it's just it kind of sold it to
something deadly
you sure they're here
yeah the their car was parked outside of
allen's place we all saw it so that
means they're here all together and
about to do something
[Music]
stupid uh
[Music]
so
dude
you did it
[Music]
oh
that guard just left his post
something's going down
o'hara let's go in
say lynnae stay put
try not to give birth okay call the
local cops for backup and let's secure
this perimeter
you should follow the diagram and switch
the blue wire with the green wire i just
cut everything attached to the main
switch oh good call that won't look
weird at all
dude someone's coming
winter soldier
[Music]
what
[Music]
that sounded like on fire do you think
that could have been anything but a
gunshot maybe it was tap man
catman
dude you're tap man we made that up i
don't know sean maybe it was the catch
i'm the catch
it's an engine what happened to nobody's
here on a sunday
[Music]
i'm supposed to just sit here
all right
lilo hide out hope that decker made it
to the safe room
uh
sean
[Music]
there's a dead guy here what
is it decker
no
some random dude
what were you just openly disappointed
i'm indifferent sean
[Music]
because
that's not just some random dude
that's the
bull i
[Music]
know they just don't have it if there is
[Music]